seit nunmehr 18 Jahren besteht eine
Partnerschaft zwischen Red Bull und den
Luftstreitkräften des Bundesheeres und
die wird jetzt weiter vertieft erklärt
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
am Dienstag bei einer Pressekonferenz in
Salzburg und betont dabei die
Wichtigkeit der umfassenden
militärischen Landesverteidigung mit all
ihren Komponenten und diese umfassende
Landesverteidigung die wiederzubeleben
insbesondere die geistige was wir zu
verteidigen haben hier natürlich wenn
wir an unseren Luftraum denken dazu
brauchen wir Partner dazu brauchen wir
Partner den gerade die geistige
Landesverteidigung die darf nicht am
Kasernen zahnenten dort muss sie erst
beginnen Teil der Partnerschaft zwischen
ÖBA und Red Bull sind gemeinsame
abfangübungen in der Luft
wenn man heute diese gemeinsame abfangen
Übung gesehen hat dann ist das ein
Bereich der uns helfen wird uns als
österreichisches Bundesheer helfen wird
ich bin dankbar wir sind dankbar dafür
dass wir die Profis als pflegerische
Darsteller in der Luft haben werden bei
so wichtigen militärischen Übungen die
Partnerschaftsurkunden werden direkt vor
dem Hangar 7 feierlich überreicht